You guys ready? Good evening.
I'm Captain Dory Corn with the
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department. I currently oversee
our homicide, sex, crimes, and
abuse neglect sections and
tonight, I'm here to brief you
on a homicide that involved
multiple victims. At 830 PM,
this evening, we received a 911
call regarding a shooting. That
happened inside of a hotel room
near the thirty-four hundred
block of Las Vegas Boulevard.
The initial details indicated
that three people have been
shot and that one of them was
deceased. Our officers
immediately responded They
actually arrived on scene with
approximately within about a
minute of the initial call and
then what they discovered was
that three people had been
shot. One of them was deceased.
Our officers immediately began
providing medical attention so
did security personnel. The two
other persons had been shot
were immediately transported to
UMC Hospital.
And then we immediately began
securing the scene as we
normally do on a shooting like
this.
It's still early into the
investigation. We're still
determine exactly what
happened. What we can tell you
at least preliminarily.
That we there was an
altercation that happened in
the room between four
individuals. We believe all
known to each other. We believe
it was a nice incident that
happened inside of the room and
that during that altercation,
one individual ended up
shooting three other
individuals. The other two
individuals that were
transported are adult females.
They are in critical condition
or shot multiple times. And
then in the other deceased,
unfortunately, he's a male
victim. Right now, we are
asking the public as we
normally do on any types of
incident like this. If you have
any information related to this
incident, please call Crime
Stoppers. Provide any
information you can. And then
I'll just kind of add just one
note which is, you know, these
types of incidents, any types
of extreme violence that
happens in our city, we take
very seriously. You've seen it
with all the investigations we
conduct. We're fortunate to
have the best homicide
investigative unit in the
country with the highest
clearance rates for a reason.
So, we're confident we will
this case. The suspect is
currently outstanding. Uh we
believe he is a black male
adult. Little heavier set. Um
but we do have good
information, good leads that
we're working and as I said, we
have a lot of confidence that
we will catch the the killer in
this case and we will close
this investigation as we always
do. Other than that, it's there
there's no other disruption to
the Las Vegas Strip or any
other area right now. We've
limited the any kind of traffic
closures. Initially, the
response required some you
know, extra police presence
as we were trying to figure out
exactly what had occurred but
at this time, there should be
really nothing visible or
disruptive to the general
public and no further threat at
this time that we believe is
you know, opposed to the
general public. With that, I
have time for a few questions
and we gotta get back to the
investigation. Give me
approximate age of the deceased
Also adult male approximately I
believe 40s or 50s. Were these
people visiting town or did
they happen to live here? Uh we
don't know if they currently
live here but there is a local
Nexus. We're not we're not
certain exactly if they
revisited or but there is a
local addresses associated to
at least one of the
individuals. We heard reports
that was on the floor. So as of
now we we secured off a variety
of areas because we're still
trying to determine exactly
where the entire crime scene
is. But we're confident to say
it was isolated inside of a
room in one of the properties
Have you guys talked to the
surveillance department? Is
there surveillance cameras
within that hallway? You know
what? Uh at this time, we're
still exploring all
investigative leads that
includes picking up all of the
surveillance data that we
potentially could get but I
will point out that we've the
security personnel and our
partnerships in general all
across the strip have been
remarkable. Uh not just in in
this case but all the all of
the incidents that we've had on
Las Vegas Strip. We have a
great partnership with all of
our hotel partners. In this
particular case, security was
hand in hand working with us
from the very beginning making
this very effective
investigation and a lot of
credit goes to them and our
officers for the immediate
response time to be here within
a minute of a shooting
happening and to be able to
provide medical attention could
make a difference potentially
for the other victims. When you
say a minute, is that just to
further to the actual room
itself? I'm not sure exactly
but I can tell you that within
a minute of the call coming in
and nine one one call, we had
officers already announcing
that they're arriving on scene.
Uh that maybe the initial
property or maybe in the
elders, not really sure. Uh
just have one maybe one or two
more questions. Yes. Everyone
remain pretty calm, security
anything to add on you know, I
think that the public here has
a lot of confidence in their
police department and so when
they saw our officers arriving
pretty quickly and handling
business, I think that
reassured everyone and kept
things calm and helped. Same
thing for the security
personnel. I think they were
able to maintain calm and we
didn't see any major
disruptions fortunately. Amen.
I'm sorry. My name? Oh, sure.
My name is Dory Corin, D O R I
K O R E N, the captain over
homicide sex crimes bureau.
Thank you, folks. I appreciate
it. Unfortunately, we have to
get right back to the
investigation but thank you.
You guys have a good night.
Thank you.